We’ve had to wait a long time to see NASA’s
monster Space Launch System arrive at Launch
Pad 39B at the agency’s Kennedy Space Center
in Florida.
The SLS is as famous for its height as it
is for its delays.
NASA promised to launch the mega-rocket as
early as 2017 only to postpone it again and
again.
Its maiden voyage - without a crew aboard
- is now scheduled for this summer.
Although the SLS is setting the stage for
America’s return to the moon, possibly by
2025, it’s unlikely to be used for long.
This may in fact be the beginning of the end
for the SLS.
The SLS is very, very expensive to fly.
NASA’s independent watchdog revealed the
cost of launching the SLS and Orion spacecraft
just once is $4.1 BILLION!
Inspector General Paul Martin called it “unsustainable”.
That figure, by the way, is eight times higher
than NASA’s estimate of $500 million per
launch.
One of the reasons the cost is so high is
that the monster rocket is not reusable.
After the SLS lifts off and burns through
the fuel in the boosters and core stage, it
drops them, kind of like how a hiker drops
a heavy backpack to climb the last few miles
to the top of a mountain.
So why has NASA spent so much to develop a
rocket that can only be used once?
Former senator Bill Nelson, who now runs NASA
as the administrator, explains that
"The program is an economic engine for America.
In 2019 alone, it supported 70,000 good-paying
jobs across the country.”
Spending huge amounts of money is reminiscent
of the space agency’s operations in the
60s and 70s when NASA flew 24 astronauts to
the moon as part of the Apollo program.
Yet the goal at that time was different than
it is now.
Back then, going to the moon was a political
statement - showing off America’s technological
might during the Cold War standoff with the
Soviet Union.
Today, landing on the moon is but the first
step of a bigger plan.
In 2004, President Bush directed NASA to return
to the moon "with the goal of living and working
there for increasingly extended periods of
time."
The aim is establishing a presence on the
moon and eventually, on Mars.
Whether NASA will help get us there is uncertain.
Former NASA administrator Charles Bolden predicted
in a 2020 interview with Politico that:
“SLS will go away…It could go away during
a Biden administration or a next Trump administration…
because at some point commercial entities
are going to catch up.”
It seems they already have.
SpaceX is developing its giant Starship to
take people to the moon and Mars.
Let’s make this real.
Let’s make this real!
Starship stands taller than any of the planned
SLS models beginning with the initial configuration,
Block 1 Cargo, ending with the Block 2 Cargo.
It also touts the ability to send more tons
to low-Earth orbit.
Specs aside, what really sets the launch vehicles
apart is their price tag.
SpaceX CEO Elon Musk has said Starship could
eventually fly for just $2 million per mission.
As opposed to the SLS’ $4 billion.
Even if it costs more than $2 million it will
still be far less than the SLS because Starship
is reusable.
Both the first-stage booster, the Super Heavy,
and the upper-stage spacecraft Starship can
return to earth and fly again.
NASA was so impressed with SpaceX that it
has chosen Starship to help with the final
leg of the journey to the moon.
A modified version of Starship will help land
the first woman and next man on the lunar
surface.
The journey would begin on Earth with the
SLS which lifts the Orion spacecraft carrying
astronauts on a path to the moon, helping
it escape Earth’s gravity.
Then, Orion would meet up with a modified,
lunar variant of Starship in lunar orbit.
The crew would transfer to Starship which
would then take them
For the trip home, Starship lifts off, meets
up with Orion which was left in lunar orbit,
the crew transfers over to Orion, and returns
to Earth.
But what if Starship was used to go all the
way to the moon, without the need for the
SLS or Orion?
Starship could launch, meet up with another
starship to refuel, before journeying to the
moon.
This version of Starship is not the lunar
model - it still has the heat shield and flaps
for landing back on earth.
SpaceX isn’t the only commercial company
with big plans for space.
Blue Origin is getting another shot at securing
a NASA moon landing contract after initially
losing out to SpaceX.
Jeff Bezos’ space venture is also reportedly
trying to make its heavy-lift launch vehicle
New Glenn fully reusable like Starship.
So NASA does appear to have private options
to lean on.
In many ways, the SLS is a final hurrah for
NASA, paying homage to the days of the past.
It uses the main engines from the space shuttle.
Its twin solid rocket boosters are built on
a foundation of knowledge and experience gained
from developing the space shuttle boosters.
Once SpaceX and others test and fly their
reusable rockets successfully, the game will
change forever.
Opening up an era of space travel where trips
to space could be as frequent as planes fly.
If you're passionate about space and want
to learn more, my friends at Curiosity Stream
have a wealth of incredible documentaries
on traveling beyond our planet that will enlighten
and inspire you.
Like this one about the historic Apollo moon
landing.
There’s also a series called Space Greed
that I happen to make a guest appearance in.
Astronauts have conducted about 3,000 experiments
on the International Space Station
You can check out the full episode on Curiosity
Stream’s YouTube channel - which I’ll
link in my description.
And if you’d like to watch thousands of
captivating and educational documentaries
on Curiosity Stream, it’s only $14.99 to
sign up for a full year!
Not month, but year.
Just head to curiositystream.com/newsthink
which I’ll also link in my description and
pinned comment.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.